la Bergerie Nationale de rambouiller 220
hectares de culture 600 moutons des
vaches des poules ou encore des chèvres
mais quel chemin parcourt--il jusqu'à
nos assiettes comme beaucoup de
producteurs des Yvelines la Bergerie
Nationale favorise les circuits courts
c'est àdire un seul intermédiaire voire
même aucun entre le producteur et le
consommateur c'est positif au niveau
économique puisque on arrive à valoriser
davantage surtout si on transforme avant
le le produit et puis ben c'est vrai que
on a une sensibilité développement
durable sur le site de la bergerie et le
fait de de vendre en local qui est moins
de transport aussi pour les productions
ben c'est quelque chose qui compte
également pour nous pour faire plus de
marge et un geste pour la planète les
lieux de revente sont donc exclusivement
en île-de-fance le circuit le plus court
la boutique gourmande à la bergerie même
qui regroupe aussi des produits des
fermes alentours en première ligne les
œufs et la viande
d'agneau local c'est donc possible et
même ces vaches comme tous les animaux
de cette ferme se nourrissent du
fourrage cultivé sur place mais alors
peut-on tout produire et consommer
localement il y a des régions qui sont
qui un potentiel agronomique un nombre
de produits très grand donc tant mieux
pour eux les consommateurs peuvent
bénéficier d'un maximum de choses par
contre quand on a des régions beaucoup
plus spécialisé avec des des sols
beaucoup plus spécifiques donc des
productions plus spécialisé derrière il
faut limité à ce qui est produit
localement quoi voilà c'est un petit peu
la limite une autre limite la
transformation si on prend l'exemple des
agnaux les agneaux sont produits à la
bergerie vendus à l'Intermarché de
Rambouillet mais enttemps ils sont
abattus dans des abattoirs agréés donc
l'abattoir agréé le plus proche
aujourd'hui c'est nos Gan le retrou donc
il faut quand même compter une heure de
route et on a entendu parler cette
semaine que cet abattoir risquait de
fermer et donc dans ce cas-là les
animaux seraient abattus en Bretagne
pour être rentable les abattoirs doivent
donc faire plus de volume des abattoirs
plus gros mais du coup moins nombreux et
plus éloignés un frein évident au
circuit
court